as a dc guy no aquaman does not have
super strength he happens to be a strong
person but his power is to talk to fish
come on as you heard there he claims
that aquaman does not have super
strength absurd
and i can settle this right now not to
appeal to authority but i did consult
superman.fandom.com
one of my favorite websites quote
aquaman possesses superhuman strength on
the order of 150 times human maximum
although he's shown feats of at least 80
tons worth of striking lifting power but
his strength is always underrated
by people like ben shapiro considering
the company that he keeps superman
wonder woman martian manhunt so who are
you gonna believe ben shapiro or
superman.fandom.com
aquaman you know lives in a pineapple at
the bottom of the sea
so just the water pressure alone
that deep down we're talking like 5 000
pounds per square inch that requires you
to either be a gelatinous life form like
a jellyfish is aquaman a gelatinous life
form ben or you have to be very strong
which aquaman is
super strong boom roasted